The .exit selection called in just the same way as .enter after data bind,
represents something of the inverse of .enter.
The right circle here corresponds to every HTML or SVG element on our page.
It might have previously been bound to data, but in a new call to .data,
no longer correspond to a row in our data file.
So rather, every part of the right circle, which represents elements currently
on our page, which don't overlap with anything in the left circle,
which corresponds to rows of data, which simply leaves us.
HTML or SVG elements currently on the page which are not
bound to rows of our data.
Dot exit's usually used if you initially draw a chart and
have subselections where users can filter based on a category or
some animation where the data from one point in time to the next changes.
And often .exit is used to remove elements from the page which you
should no longer display.